[Music]
hello boys and girls this is Tim Ferriss
welcome to another episode of the Tim
Ferriss show this episode has video if
you want to check it out on youtube.com
slash Tim Ferriss but audio-only will
still work and I'll keep this interest
short I'm gonna jump straight to the
guest my guest today is a pioneer in
emotionai I will define what that means
Rana I'll call you B PhD who's also
co-founder and CEO of Affectiva and
author of the new book girl decoded
subtitle a scientist quest to reclaim
our humanity by bringing emotional
intelligence to technology a passionate
advocate for humanizing technology
ethics and AI and diversity Rana has
been recognized on Fortune's 40 under 40
list and as one of Forbes top 50 women
in tech Rana is a World Economic Forum
young global leader and co-hosted a PBS
Nova series called wonders and she's
also appeared on and appears in the
YouTube original series the age of AI
hosted by Robert Downey jr. Rana holds a
PhD from the University of Cambridge and
a postdoc at suppose doctorate from MIT
can find her on LinkedIn Kelly you be
twitter at kali ub k al io you be why by
the way instagram at rana lqb website
rana L call you become Rana
welcome to the show thank you for having
me I'm excited I am excited to have you
on and we have so much ground to cover
and I thought I would begin with a
question that will hopefully open up a
whole different doors a whole different
set of doors I think is the proper
English expression that we could
potentially walk through and it's
related to a book this is effective
computing correct me if I'm getting any
of the pronunciation wrong by Rosalind
Picard P I see ard how did this book
come into your life so I am Egyptian so
I grew up in Cairo and around the Middle
East but at the time this is like 1998 I
had just graduated from computer science
from the American University in Cairo
and my career plan at the time was to
become faculty like I'd wanted to teach
and so I knew to teach I had to do my
masters in PhD I was all very calculated
and so I was looking for a thesis topic
and my fiancee at the time went on
Amazon and he said oh you know there's
this really interesting book by this MIT
professor called Rosalind Picard called
the effective computing and we ordered
it through Amazon it took about three
months to ship it to Cairo it got held
in customs for reasons I don't really
understand but eventually I got a hold
of the book and I read it and you know I
think it's safe to say that it changed
my life because so the thesis in the
book is that computers need to
understand human emotions just the way
people do and I read the book and I was
just fascinated by this idea and it's
you know I I made that my research topic
and it became my obsession and it just
really changed the trajectory of my life
what
besides the thesis in the book had such
an impact on your or was it just that
that worldview that perspective or was
there more to the book or more to the
author yeah that's a great question um
so let's talk about the author first so
Roz is one of the few and I mean this
was true back then it's still true today
she's one of the few kind of female you
know computer science machine learning
engineers professors in the space and
you know I I kind of learned about her
over the years I've eventually actually
she so she ended up being my co-founder
many years later but there's a story
around that but but essentially I was
just fascinated by her and she you know
she's a mom she's three boys I just
thought she was like a rock star so that
was kind of one part of it but just the
way she wrote the book and how she you
know I'm very expressive as a human
being and I just really like I think
emotions really matter and are and the
way we communicate non-verbally is very
important and and it struck me that when
we think of Technology that piece of how
we communicate is completely missing and
I was like oh yeah like it seems so
obvious so I just got fascinated by the
thesis I got fascinated by the
implications like what happens when
technology becomes kind of clued in to
how we communicate that's going to
open up a whole new world of
possibilities and I was intrigued by
that
so let's travel back to that point I'm
you were with your then fiance and this
book is ordered at the time you're
planning on becoming a teacher right a
professor why were you on that track to
begin with I mean it was it take us back
to Egypt at that time were there many
women striving to be faculty members in
similar departments I'm assuming
computer science or perhaps it was a
different department maybe you could
tell us more yeah so I went to the
American University in Cairo and I
studied computer science as an undergrad
at the time most of the faculty were
we're guys except for one female faculty
dr. Hooda hosni which became my role
model and my mentor and I just wanted to
be like her like she was awesome she was
you know very smart very approachable
very fashionable and I was like ooh I
like that right and and I just wanted to
be like her and and so I devised and I
was also I mean I mean I'm a geek I'm a
geek and I'm proud of it oh I am I kind
of devised the plan I was like okay so
I'll graduate top of my class which I
did and then I was like okay I'll go get
a masters and PhD abroad because that's
what you do and then I'll come back and
you know I'll join I'll join the faculty
and so at the time because I was getting
married to my fiance and he had a
company based in Cairo coming to the US
was not an option cuz it was way too far
so he was like I'll let you go study in
the UK cuz it's kind of close enough so
I applied to Cambridge and got in and
that was kind of the impetus for going
abroad and doing this read like focusing
on this research so when did you then
end up going to the US was that a
difficult conversation with your family
or your then-fiance
walk us through how that happened
because it doesn't sound like that would
have been just a hop skip and a jump
two-second conversation
so why not gonna walk us through that
experience yeah so okay so then I moved
to Cambridge right Cambridge University
in the UK not not Cambridge
Massachusetts and the real Cambridge
memory okay the original cameras and we
got married so basically I got married
and then got the scholarship to go study
at Cambridge and my husband he's now my
husband right well he's my ex now but at
the time he was my husband he was very
supportive he was like you gotta go this
is your dream I'll support you we'll
have a long-distance relationship now my
family my parents and his parents were
like horrified they were like what you
can't do that so so I do like to give
him credit for for making this happen
and being supportive so I ended up in
Cambridge and he was in Cairo and we did
that for five years
and towards the end of my PhD Roz Picard
was visiting Cambridge UK to give a talk
there and I ended up meeting her in
person and we totally hit it off and she
said why don't you come work with me at
MIT as a postdoc and I was like oh my
god this is like a dream come true I've
been following you like forever and this
is why you know like I told her in my
story and but then I copy at it I said
that just you know you know I've I've
been married for the last five years and
have had a long-distance relationship so
I have to go back to Cairo otherwise and
I actually really said that
I said otherwise you know in Islam
because I'm Muslim my husband can marry
up to four women and if I don't show up
eventually he'll just like marry more
women so I said it half jokingly right
so she was like that's fine just like
commute from Cairo and so I commuted
from Cairo to Boston for good a good
three or four years going back and forth
between MIT and and Cairo how often did
you go back and forth or how often did
you go back to Cairo maybe it's a better
way to ask it so initially I would spend
a couple of months in Cairo and then go
spend like a few weeks in Boston and
then I I would move with my kid
to Boston over the summer so the summer
break we just all go there and so
initially that was okay so this was
between 2006 to 2009 was okay um things
began to kind of really fall apart when
I decided to start the company so at MIT
we started to get a lot of interest in
the technology and this being IIT they
really encouraged you to spin out right
so in 2009 she not started Affectiva and
I was literally spending two weeks in
card 2 in Boston two weeks two weeks in
Boston it was insane and that was when
like just it was out of balance
everything was out of bounds and was
tough it was tough and-and-and you know
I'm divorced now so you know you can
imagine how that didn't feel very well
it was just it was I think in retrospect
it was just not a very healthy lifestyle
and I and I and I yeah I want be in that
place again I wouldn't want others to be
in that I talked publicly about that
time yeah well let's let's hop around
chronological a little bit we're gonna
come back of course to starting the
company in that decision but for people
who don't have any real firsthand
exposure to the Middle East
much less Egypt for instance mm-hmm what
was it like growing up in Egypt and
based on at least some of my reading you
for instance wore a hijab for quite some
time and we're not talking a short
period of time maybe you could also
speak to that yeah yeah and it sounds
like you spent some time and that you've
been to Jordan it sounds like I'm in
Jordan and I've spent some time in a few
places in the Middle East but not in
Egypt and when I was we chatted a little
bit before we started recording and I
only have a few words here and there in
Arabic but it's levity in Arabic right
it's it's what what you'd run across in
Jordan or Lebanon and I remember though
having many people recommend
that I not study the standard arabic
textbook Arabic but that I study
Egyptian Arabic because all of the as
they put all the entertainment and
movies that I might want to consume
would be in Egyptian Arabic needless to
say I didn't get that far
but I haven't spent any time in Egypt
well your Arabic is pretty good and
you're right about Egyptian accent
that's kind of the most common but but I
think the key thing is like there's no
one middle east and there's no one you
know forum I grew up in a family that's
kind of an interesting way quite
conservative but also quite liberal so
my parents were very pro education they
sent us to the video they put all their
money towards our schooling and they
made a point during the summers that we
travel abroad and experience kind of
other cultures and I think that's why
like I was so comfortable moving from
one country to another and ending up in
the United States right when did your
parents do sorry to interject but what
did your parents do professionally okay
so my parents met so my dad taught
computer programming in the 70s and my
mom was probably the first female
programmer in the Middle East she
attended his class and he hit on her and
they ended up getting married so so I
guess I should give them a little bit of
credit for ending up being a computer
scientist I'm sure they had something to
do with that that's that's so so they
both my my mom was a computer programmer
at the bank of National Bank of Kuwait
so we were in Kuwait for a while and my
dad is he's always worked in technology
and culturally what was it like where
you grew up or or within the family you
said that they were for instance on one
hand very less sure with the right a
cosmopolitan perhaps in right their
perspective and drive related to
education and and what were the other
ingredients in the household there was
there's definitely like clear gender
roles so even though my mom worked her
entire life it was always she was not
allowed to ever talk about her job post
you know she would
you work at 3 p.m. be home like whatever
4 p.m. when we got back from school and
that was it she was never allowed to
take a conference call at home in the
evening never allowed to travel for work
and I didn't realize that until I was an
adult like I just assumed this was the
way it was but it did hamper her you
know career progression and it was this
implicit understanding that's this is
your role this is my role and we all
stick in our lane so that was
interesting we were for example I have
two younger sisters so our three
daughters and I was not allowed to date
until after college so very very strict
and I basically married the first guy I
met right so that was that's interesting
I have a debate with my 16 year old
daughter right now who's a junior in
high school about like my mom were in
the u.s. now like that's a different set
of rules anyway so so there's that too
right so it's kind of interesting right
very strict very conservative but also
like like go kick ass kind of thing so
how did you relate to for instance the
not dating until college I think that's
what you just said if remember correctly
at the time were you accepting of that
resistant to that embrace did you
embrace that how did you relate to it at
the time I was like I caught myself a
nice Egyptian girl I never challenged my
parents it's like the weirdest thing I
just like I you know lots of trust and
you know they trusted me I trusted them
I never challenged the rules I just was
super obedient and I was always looking
for like the the gold star right like I
was the gold star daughter
yeah and so now I'm kind of trying to
like redefine what that really means and
for and for people who are maybe
thinking to themselves I can't believe
Tim asked about a hijab that's so
stereotypical how dare he first of all
it's based on my own research and
reading in preparation for this
conversation could you speak to as I
understand it your decision to wear a
hijab and when you
or it and why you stuff yes yeah so this
is this is actually like I am glad you
asked that because a lot of people just
assumed that I was forced to wear it I
was actually one of the first women in
my family to decide to put it on and and
so even my family we're like really
you're gonna wear a hijab and I and I
did that because it was a time in my
life where I became very religious and
very spiritual and I you know I wanted
to do it and I asked how has how old
were you at the time I was I was
probably like in my 20s yeah yeah of
course yeah this was 22 or 23 just
gotten married was just about to move to
Cambridge and I decided actually what
happened is one of my dad's really close
friends got a heart attack and just died
all you know unexplained I don't know it
just really hit me and so I decided to
put it on and I wore it for 12 years you
know through Cambridge through MIT and
and and then in 2012 I can't a Hulk a
host of factors right and so when I wore
it like you know when I first wore it
actually and moved to Cambridge that was
during September 11th and so my parents
thought I was like you know this Muslim
in the UK they were concerned for my
safety and so I actually switched the
hijab for a hat so I wore a hat for like
a you know a few months in Cambridge
just because you you you're supposed to
wear it like everywhere so I would show
up to class and hats I'm just like it
was like really awkward and then I just
decided to like go back to my head job
and and I think people were often always
respectful I never felt discriminated
against and and I just felt like people
were curious right like I get all sorts
of like interesting question but yeah
thousand and twelve I'd take it off what
was the host of factors if you don't
mind me prying a little bit like what
what suddenly or not so suddenly maybe
it was over a period of time but what
what were the things that prompted you
taking it off I think so at the time I
was doing the
commute between Boston and Cairo right
and and i just i don't know i realized
that the closest people my closest
friends and my closest contacts in the
u.s. we're not muslims but they were
awesome people and we shared the same
core values right like yeah maybe they
didn't pray five times a day but they
were very honest high integrity
hard-working like all the things i cared
about and so i just started thinking
like all the assumptions around religion
and acceptance of the other i don't know
i just had a ton of questions so that
was one factor and then the political
situation in egypt was quite challenging
that was at the time where the muslim
brotherhood were taking over and they
were like rolling back all of like the
women's rights and all of that and so I
was like ooh that's not my Islam like
that's not what I subscribed to and I
was going through the divorce and it
just felt like I need a Arana 2.0 it
just didn't feel like me more you know I
just wanted to feel like look cool it
you know feel and look cool and and it's
quite actually controversial to take it
off and so I was really really scared
what peope you know what people around
me would think so there was a lot of
fear it took a lot of courage to to take
that step but yeah I did it and I would
just tell people it's the same meat
right I didn't really fundamentally
change at the core yeah thank you for
answering that I just I think it's so
important we're gonna get of course to I
mean very quickly
in fact I've we're gonna jump around a
bit stochastically here
I'm sure I'm using that word incorrectly
but nonetheless here we go but I really
find that at least these types of
conversations with longer format allow
you to begin to understand the
connective tissue and sort of sub
currents that have formed people as they
then turn into these people on the
marquee who are doing these incredible
things professionally so I appreciate
you
shirring and i think it's i think it's
important to have that background and
let's talk about what the the one of
many things that jumped out at me as I
was prepping for this and I know that
this is not in order
but using if I'm getting this correct
emotion AI or affective affective let's
see if I can do this correctly computing
to help those with autism or who are on
the spectrum of I guess OB this is gonna
sound redundant but autistic spectrum
disorder I'm not I'm not sure what the
proper kind of DSM terminology is right
now I would love to get there both in on
the way there could you just define what
artificial intelligence is for those who
may be confused because it's used so
frequently often misused in the context
of what you do and then what we're going
to be talking about is one example of
that what is artificial intelligence so
artificial intelligence is this I guess
field of study that is trying to
replicate human intelligence right and
but if you look at human intent and then
there's like you know there's ways to
affect that so for example machine
learning is a subcategory within the
field of computer science which allows
you to implement artificial intelligence
so it's kind of a mechanism to get you
to artificial intelligence now at all of
forms of artificial intelligence the
part that I find you know the most
exciting is this idea that okay if you
look at human intelligence we have IQ
which is your cognitive intelligence and
of course it's really important but we
also know from years and years of
research that your emotional
intelligence is equally important people
who have higher IQs or emotion quotients
they're just like more likable people
they're more persuasive you can get them
to you know follow you and get inspired
and and actually people with higher IQs
are just like better partners and
they're better you know better leaders
and everything so so I
think that this is true for technology
that interacts with people as well so
it's not just so I think technology
that's like interacting with us on a
day-to-day basis like your device or
social robot or Siri or whatever Alexa
need to have both IQ and EQ and the
conversation has always focused very
heavily on the IQ and I'm and I'm like
an advocate for bringing EQ into the
equation let's use let's use that as a
segue so the the technology that you
ended up working on as it relates to
autism and many other things but how did
that come about and what form did it
take so you know when I first got to
Cambridge so here I was you know I I was
like a new new bride you know just like
my first experience living away from my
family and I and I get to Cambridge and
I just like focus on work right on
coding and so I had this like aha moment
that oh my god I was spending more time
on my laptop than I was with any other
person and and but this laptop was
completely oblivious to how it was
feeling right but I think even worse I
had this realization that a lot of our
communication is MIDI through technology
and the most kind of ubiquitous form of
communication is actually through text
which which if you look at how humans
communicate less than ten percent of how
we communicate is text is the words we
use ninety percent is nonverbal facial
expressions hand gestures vocal
intonation x' and all of that I felt
like just got lost in how I communicated
particularly with with my husband at the
time and I just felt like we I wanted to
change that so I wanted to build emotion
AI to make human-computer interfaces
better but ultimately it's all about
human connection I want to make sure
that as we move to a more digital
universe we're not losing our EQ right
we still can reserve and even maybe
augment our emotional intelligence and
this is where autism came in because it
was a clear example it's almost an
extreme example of people who struggle
with EQ
and where technology could be like a
hearing aid like people wear hearing
aids to augment their hearing and I was
like what if you could build an
emotional prosthetics that could help
bogman to your EQ whatever that was like
well it looked like Google glass this
was before Google glass exists let's see
you know so say I have autism I would
put on these glasses they had little
cameras the camera would point outward
at whoever I was interacting with so say
I'm talking to you and it would say oh
Tim looks really interested in what
you're saying he's nodding his head or
Tim looks bored to death maybe you
should stop talking and like ask a
question or something you don't look
like you're bored to death I hope not
that sort of thousand-yard stare like
dumb deer look is just my my standard so
don't analyze people's expressions in
real-time and feed the kids real-time
feedback and it would give them almost
like positive reinforcement every time
they even look to the face because
individuals on the autism spectrum like
find it really really hard to even
engage in a face-to-face conversation
because it's so overwhelming and this
would be visual feedback on the the lens
of the glasses that they would see like
it or was it audio feedback what type of
feedback did they receive um we did this
was back in 2006 so it was even like
before smart video it was like really
early on so we had the feedback on the
auditory through a Bluetooth kind of
like pets whatever your pods yeah and
but now we work company called brain
power and they actually use Google glass
and on our technology and the feedback
is visual through the Google glass
heads-up display so this this is
fascinating to me in so many levels and
one expression that jumped to mind as as
you're describing autism and just for
simplicity we'll use use the the term
autism being an extreme case to study it
comes from I want to think a documentary
called objectified about design and
industrial design and there's an
expression that I want to say someone
from frog design used and that is the
extremes and form the mean but not vice
versa in the census by starting with the
extreme cases so in this case in the in
the dock it was designing I think hedge
clippers or something for say the
paraplegic and the morbidly obese if you
if you solve for those edge cases then
you will find applications for the
people in the middle so this use of
technology with people with an autism
diagnosis is interesting to me first for
that just that like corollary and then
second I'd love to know if you observed
any learning curve that carried over to
non augmented reality in the sense that
were did you observe anyone with autism
after being given positive feedback for
certain behaviors right if we're looking
at sort of shaping of behavior did you
see that carryover or were they much
like someone with a hearing it dependent
on the hearing aid that is like the key
question so we totally saw improvement
in the kids we were working with while
they wore the device we didn't get round
to testing through this particular grant
whether this learning generalized right
beyond the the device but this is what
brainpower this company is totally
focused on so they've now deployed about
400 of these Google glass devices and
the key question is is this an
augmentation device or is it a learning
device and can you write off of it and I
don't know the answer to that it's still
very early days I would I mean this is
pure speculation on my part which is
maybe irresponsible because obviously
the studies need to be done but I would
imagine I would imagine I'd be very
surprised if there isn't some degree of
carryover I mean assuming at you know
working memory and memory consolidation
and these various things are functioning
in these subjects but I would be
astonished if there weren't some degree
of carryover I mean if they can
understand the feedback loop it would
sort of imply to me right this right
once you get that feedback loop work
ethic I think you're right I mean there
are like I'll never forget this like one
of the kids who he worked with at the
school and Providence like he would
never make any face eye contact with me
and this one particular day like after
six months of this training program he
lowers like he had like this iPad
between me and him and then he lowered
it and he may direct I can't and it was
just a powerful moment of human
connection and I don't think you can
unlearn that or undo that do you know
what I mean I'm sure for him I hope for
him he you know he can build on that
yeah amazing I can't wait to see what
what comes to that as they deploy more
units and gather more data when did you
know what oh sorry go ahead well I was
gonna ask you because it's an it's kind
of an adjacent area but I don't know if
you were planning to go there at some
point the applications generally to
mental health right what's your question
and sure yeah cuz that's an area that
I'm very passionate about and I feel
like this technology can can really help
well let's let's jump right into it I
think that's a great place to go so
where could this or where is this being
deployed where could it be deployed and
we could focus on the mental health if
you want to focus on that first we could
certainly touch on that first um just
because I mean it's it's not directly
related to autism but it was this
realization that oh my goodness in the
mental health space the gold standard
and you know when you go to a doctor
today they don't they don't ask you like
Tim what's your temperature blood
pressure they just measure it right but
in in mental health the gold standard is
still like a survey you know on a scale
from one to ten like how depressed are
you are you six or eight right or like
how suicidal are you and that's like
like how do you how do you answer that
right right and also like you see a
doctor like what once a week like what
happens in all the instances when you're
not with that person and that's really
powerful data right so I feel like this
kind of technology I mean that and then
the other piece of it is we're always on
our devices so that's an opportunity to
collect
your baseline and then know if you
deviate from it because we know that
there are very strong facial and vocal
biomarkers of things like depression and
suicidal intent and Parkinson's so I
feel very strongly that there are
applications where this technology can
can just like bring objective data took
yet to quantifying these things I bet
that strikes me is so important as you
noted because we're really still in the
stone ages when it comes to psychiatric
diagnostics related to most of what we
would consider mental health or mental
health disorders and what you're
describing allows you to gather a
baseline over time right longitudinally
you can gather a tremendous amount of
data because my baseline is going to be
different from half the people I met in
Silicon Valley who were bordering on the
spectrum or on the spectrum I mean the
the facial expression baseline is going
to be and the tonality baseline is going
to be very different so you need much
likelihood with blood tests and
biomarkers you need to know what your
baseline ranges and and like that as you
mentioned the surveys are so problematic
I remember recently I did a number of
experiments with these were with sort of
biochemical interventions it's a long
story that I won't get into right now
but in the first session they said well
from zero to ten how anxious are you
feeling literally no idea how to answer
that right right but yeah but I know but
but I know I'm gonna be coming in for
five sessions so I'm gonna give you a
five now and then the next time I come
in at least we can figure out if I'm
feeling more or less but if I start at a
two then where am I going to go if I'm
feeling less anxious so let me start
with a five but it becomes very muddy
it's not really how anxious it's you
kind of yeah I'm verbalizing I'm sort of
yeah I'm verbalizing the whole thing so
that's that's exactly what other what
are their application
Asians are you most excited about and is
it mostly focused on recognition of
facial characteristics at this point the
focus I mean our yeah the may our main
product is basically mapping your like
using computer vision to understand what
your face is saying we've also added
voice like vocal intonation x' as well
and it's a quite complex problem as I'm
sure you would imagine right like you
know I'm sure we can think of situations
where you've misread people's facial
expressions right so it's i it's not
just about like detecting a smile it's
like what type of smile like what else
is happening on the face are you like
throwing your eyebrows are you squinting
are you smirking all of that so the idea
is to take all of that information and
infer how's the person feeling or what
are they thinking and the applications I
mean we're focused as a company we're
focused on two particular industries one
is market research so just kind of
trying to understand how to consumers
emotionally engage with products and
services and content so when they listen
to your podcast are they like rolling
their eyes or are there anything that's
50 pressure but how are they emotionally
engaging with contents that's a key
question and that of course drives a lot
of consumer behavior like word of mouth
or you know purchase decisions and
things like that and then so that's one
area and then the other area where we're
very focused on is the automotive
industry so detecting things like driver
fatigue if you're texting while driving
or you know distraction and then there's
applications in the Robo taxi world when
when we get there Robo taxi meaning
autonomous vehicles or yes okay we're
gonna we're going to come back to
autonomous in a minute but have you had
companies or people reach out to you for
for instance analysis
micro-expressions if that's even a real
term I've heard it use related to truth
versus lying and the reason I ask is
that I've have a friend when I went to
school with a classmate who has ended up
working with farmer people from the
intelligence community mm-hmm at a firm
and their sole job is to watch political
announcements earnings announcements etc
to try to parse as humans what they
believe is true and what they believe is
untrue and there are companies that pay
and I'm sure governments that pay lots
of money for their interpretation but
you might say to yourself well that's
that's that's interesting also because
at one point in time humans were the
best chess players in the world now
computers are have you had have you had
people reach out to you for those types
of applications the answer is yes so so
first of all micro-expressions is is is
a real term and it represents so when
there is when you are lying basically
there's this leak like a facial
expression leak it's usually like a very
short-lived subtle like fleeting facial
expression like an eye twitch or a lip
twitch and with the right frame rate
like if you're using a high-speed camera
you can actually detect that right like
so our technology can totally do that
today now that doesn't mean that we do
that so we have a very we're very values
driven you know our first use case was
autism and and I think the whole not I
think the whole thesis of the company
and my mission is to just bridge the
connection gap between people and so we
have very clear values around opt in and
privacy and so we've turned millions and
millions of dollars of potential funding
and business basically from the
government that wanted us to pivot
towards this lie detection and
surveillance universe and it was
sometimes it was hard like there was a
time when we almost run out of money as
a company and we had this opportunity to
take almost 40 million dollars from an
intelligence agency and
to think hard about it because we didn't
know if they had an alternative so it it
could have meant the end of this whole
act Eva journey but I just didn't it's
not at all why we started the company
and it did not match our like our North
Star you know and it just I just so
anyway so we veered away from that and
we were able so raised less money but
from investors who we felt like shared
our vision for where we could take this
well I commend you for that and that's
hard as hell to do especially when you
might face an existential financial
threat as a start-up exam and I suspect
we'll probably come back to the sort of
light versus dark utopian versus
dystopian later we might not but I think
this is a good time to hop back to
autonomous vehicles self-driving cars
and that is in part because from my
understanding and I'm not a computer
scientist but speaking to people in
Silicon Valley when I was there and
certainly speaking to technologists now
that many of the questions that used to
be thought exercises and say philosophy
classes epistemology 101 etc or ethics
101 the trolly scenario right where you
have to choose between killing one
person of one type or five people of
another type let's just say one elderly
person versus or five elderly versus one
school child etc these types of
decisions are now decisions that on some
level need to actually be thought about
encoded into how a vehicle behaves and I
bring that up because in some respects I
suppose many people would think of
emotions as not necessarily the final
frontier but something that seems
innately human difficult for computers
to understand and so I wonder what did
you learn in trying to teach computers
how to understand emotions or
you emotions about your own emotions
how's that impacted if at all how you
relate to your own emotions or
expression yeah a lot
i I would by the way I was not expecting
that to be the question Thomas vehicle's
question it was it was a bit of a legend
so I yeah yeah it's been it's been tough
because I I just shut out my emotions
for the long I mean it's really ironic
but I just grew up in a very like we
work hard we like no-nonsense and so you
know I just shut out my emotions and I
didn't acknowledge it to others so I
always looked like I was strong and like
always like bubbly and happy and just
never ever shared or showed my true
emotions but I also think it's even
worse than that I think I never
acknowledged my own emotions to myself
until quite recently actually when I
when when I was going you know through a
divorce and moving to the United States
with my kids as a single mom and
starting the company there was just a
lot going on and I took on journaling
and I journal a lot and that's where I
just started like just like really
embrace embracing my emotions like the
good and the bad and the ugly right and
just getting it all out there and I just
learned a lot about you know what what
it looks like and what it feels like to
have these emotions and so and so in a
really interesting way this journey of
figuring out how to teach machines kind
of a range of emotions is also like a
journey for a personal journey for me to
learn about my own emotions and and
accept them and and even share them with
others like I've you know I've I've kind
of made like a 360 way or 180 whatever
like where I started as being this kind
of very like there's always walls and
barriers around me and I and now I'm
like taking those down and I feel like
it's been amazing because when you share
with people people
reciprocate and what I often felt like
Oh nobody else in the universe feels the
same way I'm wrong when I when I share
people are like oh my god like this
resonates so much with me I've been
through something similar and just this
builds this like amazing connection so
um yeah I don't know if that answers
your question no it does it does I are
there any what do you think are and
we're gonna come back to the journaling
for sure what are any misconceptions
that people have about emotion I don't
know if there are I don't know if there
are any but how would you respond to
that yeah
so when yeah so when we first started
Affectiva Rose and I were out raising
money for the company right and so we
were these two women scientists raising
money from a male-dominated Silicon
Valley which is where we did our most of
our pitching and we were seeing an
emotion company yeah Sand Hill Road lots
lots of blue button downs exactly and so
we would avoid using the word emotion at
any cost that's why we actually called
the company Affectiva because effect is
a synonym for emotion but it doesn't
have the same kind of feministic
connotations of emotion like who needs
emotions and so we would avoid talking
about it like like ever it's the e word
you never talk you never bring up that
you word um but I think I think the
universe is I think the world has moved
from that point I mean this was 20 years
ago
well I started research and in the space
20 years ago we pitched you know we
started a Factiva ten years ago I think
now there's more realization that
emotions matter emotions drive our
decisions in good ways that in sometimes
irrational ways emotions are at the
center of how we empathize and connect
and learn and memory right like I think
I do actually realize like businesses
but also just the average drill like has
more respect for emotions so that's been
good well let's let's talk about Sand
Hill Road for a second I'll describe
in order for folks who might not know it
and why would you know it unless you've
spent time near it
it's a Sand Hill Road if you can imagine
imagine Silicon Valley as a city which
it is it's an entire area but let's just
pretend it's a city and then there's a
gated community where the Masters of
finance live and they're kind of like
the iron bank in Game of Thrones if you
want if you want money chances are at
least this was certainly true in the 90s
and the early 2000s it spread out more
there are more financial options but if
you want the highest density of people
who can write big checks and who have
prestigious firm names then Sand Hill
Road is this one spot where you have
just office next to office next to
office next to office next to office
based on some of my reading you also I
don't know at what point but had your
son Adam with you right and and so I
would love for you to speak to what that
experience was like number one and then
number two what worked in the pitch I
like what what did you find actually
grabbed people what was it in the
picture in the deck whatever you you
might remember from the presentation
that worked I remember yeah okay so so
this is 2009 and we decide we we were
getting so much commercial interest in
the technology and so I originally
thought the solution was to just hire
more PhD students in the lab and the lab
director at the time Frank Moss said no
no no this is not research anything you
got us leave the lab like start a
company so um so we put together a pitch
deck and we had a lot of like we were
very lucky we had a lot of mentor MIT
who would like poke at it and say no no
this doesn't work like iterate that
anyways we were eventually ready and in
the fall of 2009 we headed to the Bay
Area and to do our Sand Hill Road show
and we just I mean we were able to get
all the meetings we wanted so that was
great
but I showed up with my six-year-old as
six-month-old son Adam and we had lined
up a babysitter to take him on you know
for during the day when we were
presenting but this one particular day
she bailed on me she called me in the
morning she's like I'm not feeling well
can't take him like what and so you know
you're not you're not gonna ditch an
investor meeting so I show up with him
in the car seat and I walk in and there
was this like very nice-looking kind of
kind looking assistant at the front desk
and I said hey can you keep an eye on
him he's a really good baby we're just
gonna go half the meeting inside and and
you know I was I was and she didn't have
an option really like I was asking her
for a permission I was like like taken
it was good it worked it worked out he
was he was well behaved I mean so if you
just make it work right um and actually
we hired our first CEO that way too we
had dinner with with this guy who again
in the Bay of same trip Bay Area he was
an introduction through one of our
investor potential investors and I
showed up with Adam and I was like do
you mind like I don't have anything I
don't know wait to leave him and he was
like no it's fine I have three boys it's
okay and so I was like okay he's a good
guy we're gonna hire you
Wow is that was that that was that I
just had to like make it work right and
then on the pitch like what worked for
the pitch we had live demos of the
technology so we would show up with an
actual live device that could measure
your emotions it would track your
expressions in real time so you would
see a real-time kind of readout of your
facial expressions and we always always
I mean people were just fascinated by
the technology they didn't know it
existed it would always open up people's
minds to potential applications like
people would say oh if you thought about
using it in retail or like you know you
know automotive or dating like they
would just like it would just get
people's creative juices flowing so I
think that worked but I don't think that
it was enough
to get people over the oh my god like
you are so different everything's so
different right like women scientists I
wore the hijab at the time emotions like
it was just it was like too alien I
think so it was tough yeah so you got
you got a lot of those who if you're
comfortable saying I have no idea but I
would imagine is somewhere in the in the
public record who ended up who ended up
saying yes and why do you think they
said yes instead of all contrast all the
knows um so our first very first check
came from the Valen Berg family of
Sweden a very wealthy family very fun
Tropic and and and just had a lot of
active investments the the main person
they are Peter Valen Berg Newroz from
before and had basically told her
anytime you need money just call me up
so she did that he invested but we were
able to raise money from kleiner perkins
so mary meeker was on our boards for a
while she was awesome so we did we did
end up you know raising money from from
Silicon Valley essentially well not just
Silicon Valley but for people who don't
know me kleiner perkins is one of them
consider one of the blue chips I mean
that's right that's top tier yeah yeah
and at the time they had just made their
investment in Spotify and they could
really see how like your emotions and
understanding your emotions could drive
music selection and just like excuse her
experience in general so they were you
know they they saw they saw that
potential and Mary specifically I think
she still does this every year puts out
her so the annual I don't know how to
pop properly describe it what would be
like trend forecast I don't know the
proper descriptor to use clearly I'm not
fully on top of it but if people look up
mary meeker emmy ekt are very very
impressive woman and why do you think
well i guess you've already in part
answered this was it a fast yes for
kleiner perkins or did it take a while
to court them
actually that was an inbound from Selena
Chow who is she heads up the horizons
invest venture fund which is the venture
fund for lika shipping who's this like
super you know top billionaire in China
and she emailed us out of the blue and
said I want to invest in you guys and we
were like but we're not raising hitch
astrayed is you know we had just raised
her round of funding she's like I don't
care I'm just investing so we met her
and she Cohen vests with Mary often so
we met both of them and the Spotify
offices I think it was in New York and
they were just amazed you know like a
sign from everything I was like wow
these two women are just powerhouses so
they were really you know they they
would just I just made it happen it was
amazing
that's actually yeah you can I will say
this is not my typical experience
raising money that was a not liar
yeah well the idea I think I think
they're really really good investors who
can see where the puck is going are
outliers to begin with right so you're
just not gonna run into that many and
one of the common traits I've seen
particularly with really I don't want to
call it pure technology play but
something that is deeply technical the
investors who are best at that will
often reach out to authors of white
papers and say hey I know you haven't
built a company but you should not want
to give you all the money listen to them
right yeah a lot of lot of them are
really really good you mentioned dating
could you speak to that for a second
because that was the aside putting aside
the the truth not truth application that
was one that that's that did jump to
mind partially because I want to say I
at some point read a report of some
psychologists maybe it was a behavioral
psychologist who could look at video
footage of couples and predict with some
unbelievable high percentage hit rate
like 95 percent
accuracy whether they would still be
together a year later or ten years later
or whatever it was I can't recall the
exact specs on that I what do you think
the applications are for dating or it
could be or do you think that's is that
a fool's errand I think there's
definitely play there so the guy you're
you're talking about is John Gottman and
he focuses on couples therapy and you're
right so he was just from like watching
you know a few seconds of video of a
couple kind of interacting with each
other he'll look for expressions like an
upper lip razor which is an expression
of contempt and he's able to predict
like if they're getting divorced or will
they be able to work through that but
let's like back up right like dating
right I think there's huge potential
there I mean I think maybe that's like
maybe that's the killer app or or
whatever because because because because
when you're seeing people's profiles you
subconsciously like perk up if somebody
looks interesting or you like me right
you have all these like subconscious
expressions and if you are able to
capture those I think that could be
really fascinating but I think the real
killer feature would be if you're able
to take all of my nonverbals as I'm
going through all these profiles and or
even like as you start engaging with
somebody online and turn it into a will
we have chemistry when we meet in the
real world because that's the key
question right right and so if you can
use all of that information and turn it
into a predictor of yeah level of
chemistry like butterfly effect when you
meet a person and in the Real IRA I
think that's really interesting so um I
haven't figured out how to do that but
but I think there's a lot of application
no I I don't know I do agree yeah I mean
I think it could be I think it could be
a huge application and I don't know what
form it would take precisely but if you
imagine something like a shove my age
here maybe but you have effectively a
tinder or Pandora where you're summing
up something down
and then over time based on the emotion
AI analysis of those profile pics or
better yet video if there were a short
video clip I may because exactly then
you could you could effectively create a
signature of attraction right or a
signature of my excitement or a
signature of fill-in-the-blank that is
read by the camera on your laptop or on
your phone and yeah I think people would
pay for that certainly I mean let's just
say you had a dating app and there was a
five dollar pro feature per month that
right added that capability on top of
your normally static non interactive
kind of personal you as user do all the
heavy lifting version right that's
that's I think that's something a lot of
people would pay for so I find that
personally very very interesting I'm
very take it on is larger than a size
one thing when they get going let's talk
about the journaling you mentioned the
journaling I'd love to hear about the
journaling and anything else that you do
to ground yourself or keep yourself
centered when things are difficult
because you've and we may come back to
this but you've you've had tough times
you've had challenging times you've had
a lot on your plate at once can you
speak to the journaling and any other
practices that you have that have helped
you I think your journal to write I
didn't sure I've heard you talk about
that yeah so I use an app called day one
and I started I've now been journaling
out a eight or nine years pretty
consistently I find that it first of all
it's a way of
letting it all out right so I journal
openly I just like you know hopefully
this my journal will never get hacked
because if it does I'm in trouble and I
can't just hide it under my bed it's out
there in the cloud so anyway so so I
just I just just journal very openly
interestingly a while ago I went back
and looked at like the most frequently
occurring like word that I use I use and
lonely was up there fear was another one
so a lot of fear a lot of loneliness so
it's a way of getting it out there but
what I also find interesting is I often
log like celebration so I'll say you
know I am grateful for my kids I'm
grateful for like everything's falling
apart but you know what I'm in good
health I'm grateful for that I always
something like however big or small that
and I just acknowledge I try to
celebrate something so that helps so I
guess the third way the journal is very
powerful and in my experience is I look
back at all these times when it was
really challenging and when I felt like
oh my god I might not get through this
and I look back and I was like it worked
like when we were moving to the US with
my two kids and I see newly divorced
like life's falling apart my parents are
like you can't do this and it failed the
kids are gonna be miserable and I write
all of that like a lot of fear a lot of
fear a lot of people and then we moved
over here and we loved it it's amazing
and so can look back at these times and
actually when it's challenging right now
it's challenging for all of us and I
just it just helps me have this
conviction that this will tap it'll pass
it'll be fine yeah I don't know is that
your does ring true and it's very
helpful
what do you liked about day one and do
you journal three times a week five
times a week if it's kind of when you
feel the need of what are the indicators
that you need to do it but what is what
the actual practice look like is it in
the morning any specifics it you could
share would be super helpful um so what
I love the most about day one is it's
just super easy and it's it allows for
multimedia right so sometimes I'll just
take a screenshot of a cute text chat
I'll go into my journal right so there's
that or sometimes if I'm on a flight
back you know from wherever and I just
have a few moments I'll just get on a
sail fighting back from Austin I like
you know I just finished it added on it
felt really good or it didn't feel
really good or I just finished a call
with an investor it sucks whatever right
so there's no there's some it's not like
I have a fixed time because I find that
very hard to do it's usually very
impetus driven right like you know I
want to make sure that I log an event or
log a thought or log a feeling sometimes
I'll write essays like some of my
entries are super long and sometimes
it's just like two sentences you know I
try to keep it yeah I try to not super
make it super structured because then
it's hard to implement mm-hmm yeah I
think that I think complexity is not
your friend when it comes to
implementation are there any books that
you've turned to often or reread off and
gift it off in any of those things that
come to mind so I've recently been
gifting I must have given this book to
at least like three or four people
because I recently read it the obstacles
of the way right yeah I just this idea
that we all run into obstacles and we
have a choice we can just like call it
the end of the road more we just like
find a way to work through it or around
it or on top of it or whatever that's
just like really resonating with me
right now and I've been gifting the you
know even though I think the books like
a few years old now but that's fine
yeah it's written by
Bryan Holaday loose about 30 to 40
minutes where I'm sitting right now you
know you're I like I could kind of infer
that you guys are good friends yeah yeah
believe it or not I I don't think you
know this but I actually was the
publisher of his audiobook version
because I enjoyed I saw a preprint
version of the book and I said if you
want to do something with audio let me
help you
and so we publish the audio version
together yeah small world super small
world
what about fiction do you read fiction
or do not read fiction I do my favorite
book which I've now read a few times
also is Jhumpa Lahiri's the namesake you
read up I have not read it could you
could you why why is it why is it so
good for you
so it tells the story of this Indian
young man who moves to Boston to study
do his PhD so he does that and then he
brings over why he gets married and
brings over his Indian wife and they
settle in in Massachusetts and they you
know they start off in Cambridge in this
small apartment which I did too and then
they moved to the suburbs and they have
kids and then their kids grow up with
this internal conflict of whether you
know they are American are they Indian
are they both what does that mean and it
follows the journey of this family and I
first read it in 2008 2008 well and I
was between Cairo and MIT and it was
becoming clear that my life is
gravitating towards Boston with every
trip and I just read it on this flight
back to Cairo I'll never forget this I
was just like bawling I was just crying
I just hit home in such a weird way
because I think I was at this fork yeah
for crossroads crossroads crossroad and
and I and I and I just like it really
hit home and then I reread it a few
months ago and I was I cry just the same
really because I feel like oh my god I'm
like I've progress right like I'm in the
suburbs my kids are in school here I
think my kids are grappling with and all
of us like me and my kids are grappling
with ok how Egyptian are we how American
are we and how do you bring the two
together in a way that's true to who we
are so so I love that book I highly
recommend it it's amazing you know I
also strikes me that in the last few
weeks I've been reading more fiction and
I was I was a nonfiction purist for
decades and books yeah I mean would you
name it I mean self-help if we want to
go all the way back to Ben Franklin then
yes so self up biography in some
respects all books or self-help if that
makes sense even fiction man but the I
find that in the times were in right now
at the time of this recording of course
the the novel coronavirus covered 19
etcetera are causing a lot of self
quarantine isolation etc so the words
that you mentioned loneliness lonely
fear I think those are going to become
those feelings going to become more and
more present for more people and that
fiction really good fiction at least for
me has the effect of lessening both of
those feelings even if it's just for the
period of time that you're reading
particularly the books that can elicit
or paint a picture really a motive
landscape of feelings that you're having
just in this in the way that you've
shared your emotions thinking you're the
only person in the world having them and
people say oh my god that really
resonates with me and you feel less
alone and doing so both of you I would
imagine so I've been reading more
fiction so this will go on my list do
you have a recommendation I do actually
I'm only I hesitate to recommend books
that I'm only partially through but I
feel quite confident in this one and
bear with me two seconds to literally
two feet for me and I'm gonna grab it
okay alright sit it's this book here
which is I'll read it little big so lit
up little comma big by John Crowley like
Aleister Crowley so little big by John
Crowley this is I suppose you could
consider it a fantasy novel it's a bit
difficult in the beginning I'm gonna
warn people that you really need to give
it at least 30 pages I tried this book
two or three times it was gifted to me
by my brother who has a very very high
bar for all books is he's a math and
stats whiz also reads very can read very
very dense
comp type stuff and just has a very high
bar for any books that he'll read start
to finish and I couldn't get into it
because I quit within the first eight
pages and now that I'm 50 or 60 pages in
I'm 60 pages in I'm just loving it and
to give you an idea I mean this is I've
never seen I don't spend too much time
on this because this is about you and
not me but I I do think that fiction is
a really good medicine for people right
now just listen to some of these cover
quotes there and you by the way we're
gonna talk about your book you have some
amazing blurbs from people listen to a
few of these so this is for a little
little big so here's the cover quote
quote I always regularly reread a book
that I wish more people would read
little big it is literally the most
enchanting 20th century book I know
Harold Bloom yeah and then you've got
you know Los Angeles herald-examiner
says the kind of book around which cults
are formed and rightly so there's magic
here it just goes on and on Ursula K Le
Guin I believe I'm getting the name
pronounced correctly says this book is
indescribable a splendid madness or a
delightful sanity or both persons who
enter this book are advised that they
will leave it a different size than when
they came in it is a [ __ ] weird book
I'm gonna warn you in advance it's very
strange and that's part of the reason
that I like it so much it's very weird
it's not like kind of a you know Gabriel
Garcia Marquez sort of like Colombian
surrealism it's very odd but
so far I'm finding it enjoyable I will
make sure I stick through the first four
thirty pages yeah and I would recommend
getting it on Kindle because John
Crowley's vocabulary is impressively
broad and like when I read his dark
materials and the golden compass which
are categorized as young adult novels
but then contain extremely niche
nautical terminology so you'll want to
be able to look words up is what I'm
saying okay because I'm underlining
words every page or two that I don't
actually know the meaning and that's my
dog Marty if you hear it that's Molly
because we're I'm on to quarantine
vérité on this idea let's let's talk
about let's talk about your book why
with all the things you have going on
why a book III of all people know books
to do well take a lot a focus that take
a lot of energy why a book why now first
of all I find you how much work it would
have been it's pretty much like a
start-up right if you knew really how
much work it would take maybe I wouldn't
have done it so but but but the reason
the initial reason I decided to write
the book so this has been almost three
years in the making
as it was originally gonna be like an AI
book right like AI needs empathy it
needs emotion it's all about emotion AI
and why do we need a motion AI and how
do you build a motion AI and what are
the applications like it was and one of
the ethics and moral implications of all
of that and then I had a meeting with an
editor that was interested in in the
book Roger shoal penguin Random House
and it was a lunch meeting and here's
about tell me you're sorry and I grew up
in Cairo and then I you know what a job
and then I moved to came and he's like
that's the book like what and he was
like well your story of your story of
becoming you know moving from this nice
Egyptian Abbey
young woman to like CEO of an AI
venture-backed company in the u.s. that
journey of personal transformation could
resonate with people and so the more and
so we pivoted we pivoted basically and
the book became more of a memoir which
makes me sound like I'm 80 years old I'm
not and it's just this juxtaposition of
my personal journey with why and how I
you know I built this category of AI
called emotion AI so it's it's got a lot
and my I mean my reality is that both
journeys are very intertwined and so the
book kind of puts that forth what did
you learn in the course and writing the
book was there anything that came out
that surprised you thinking that you
were able to clarify in the process of
writing what what did you learn or what
surprised me about the process so the
biggest thing I I liked so I was like
Midway and not made maybe a third into
writing the book when I read Michelle
Obama's becoming and it was just so
vulnerable I was like I want to I want
to be open and how I write about this so
I went back and and kind of not rewrote
but just like rethought how I'm gonna
approach this and the thing that struck
me the most was my relationship that you
want to subdue that yeah and actually so
eirick eirick I narrated the audiobook
and there was one part in the book where
I talked about my dad and I just I just
totally broke down I mean so it's this
like very interesting relationship I
love my dad loved my dad and he's been
so supportive of my journey and my
aspirations but at the same time he is
very strict like for the longest time I
just assumed because I broke mold of
what is expected of me that he was not
proud of me like for the longest time I
just I
I just I still feel that way sometimes
that I wonder if he would rather have
had me stay in Egypt be an awesome life
be an awesome mom and give up all of
that I don't think so I mean he was in
the US a few months ago and he visited
the team and he met affic you know the
Affectiva crew and I think he looked
proud in the picture when you looked
proud but so writing through that you
know my mom and my sisters read an early
version of the book and they we're like
you can't you can't publish it like that
dad's coming out in a very bad light and
I was like what so I had to go back and
and just like really explore my
relationship with him yeah yeah
difficult was it confusing how would you
describe looking that closely at your
relationship with your dad over time I
think a lot of people have complex
relationships with at least one parent
what was that like for you because I had
found it writing about many subjects
extremely difficult sort of emotionally
impactful and some unsettling sometimes
what was that how would you describe the
experiences of looking at it
so closely for the purposes of writing I
just had to really dig deep right I
think it's it's like I had just probably
written off or like closed off major
chapters in my life where I just
wouldn't talk about it I or I talked
about it like in one sentence I'd never
go like really deep and my relationship
with my dad is one of them so I had to
like and I just like look I just broke
this pencil that's interesting okay I'm
gonna put this down I think it's just
like super complex and very
multi-layered right like like through
the divorce he was very adamant
he he took a very balanced view between
my relationship and my like he you know
with my ex and so he almost like he was
an arbitrator right he wasn't like
exclusively on my side I felt like he
was very balanced which I on the one
hand think is great but part of me was
like dad you're like my daddy gotta be
on my side and but I think he did it for
the greater good so I had to just work
through these things over like one one
day he called me up I was in Boston and
he was like quit Affectiva like just
sell it I was like what it's my company
he was like you got to come back home
fix your marriage like done with this
company and and I know where he's coming
from he's coming from a place of love
but it took me a while to process that
right yeah so things like that but he's
awesome at what feel free to not answers
if you don't want to but what what if
anything do you think has been unsaid to
your dad that would be helpful to say to
your death is there anything that comes
to mind or was there anything that came
out in the book that you feel strongly
about I don't need to dwell on this I
just I think this is part of what makes
you you and that's why I'm asking I
guess I just I I do want my dad to know
that I love him and and I guess you know
he's very close to both my sisters in a
way that I you know I don't think I've
let myself be open in that way but I
would like to because I feel like
someday I will regret you know I'll
regret not I look back and I'll say
bummer like I should have really taken
that step so I guess I would like him to
know that I would I would love to
explore kind of a closer relationship
that I think that would be that would be
cool
and I I think having written that book
I'm a lot more open I'm a lot more open
to doing that that's beautiful thank you
for thank you for answering that what's
now he has to listen to it you know
there are a few people who listen to
this make it make it active
[Music]
what's shipping a book publishing a book
is much like as you said starting a
startup it's difficult you try to you
hope to have some type of driver behind
climbing this mountain that pays off at
some point what impact and we mentioned
it at the top of the episode but girl
decoded is the title of the book
subtitle a scientist quest to reclaim
our humanity by bringing emotional
intelligence to technology what would
make this book a home run for you not
necessarily in terms of numbers of
copies sold bestseller lists and all
that but in terms of impact and it could
just be on a handful of people doesn't
need to be millions of people but what
could make this worth it for you I would
want not just women actually I think
people assume that this is you know
mainly target it's a story that's man
it's not at all just mainly targeted at
women I think it's more about people
embracing their own voice and their own
path and their own emotions and having
faith that it's it's that they can do it
right I had I mean I still have so much
doubt in my brain probably because of my
cultural upbringing that it just all
feels serial to me like III like
impostor syndrome like plus plus right
all the time and I have to work through
it and I have to you know negotiate with
with that voice and in a way like I'm my
biggest obstacle in a sad way right and
so I just people to know that it doesn't
have to be that way and you can you can
work through it and and so when people
reach out to me and they're like you
know I follow you and I just want you to
know that you've inspired me or you've
you've kind of propelled me to try X Y &
Z that just makes my day just that's
that's what helps get
through all of the crap that's out there
am I allowed to say crap
you're like right I jumped another bomb
right here you're good with this you can
use the Emer as well we've been we've
been doing a good job of using the e
word yes we have oh yeah I think that
this is really important I I really hope
the book does well and I haven't heard
the book but I think that your story is
really compelling and it also I think
highlights for me at least your story
and also the technology that you're
helping to develop that were we're we're
all in this together and that that's not
meant to sound cliched and kumbaya but
particularly when it's when we're
experiencing say a scare and possible
health crisis as we are right now it's
very easy to feel isolated and even one
thing that struck me is as I was doing
reading about the technology and so on
that I think I think the word diversity
has become a hot button in the sense
that it's it's something that a lot of
people overuse it's something that other
people avoid using at all costs because
they've become oversensitive or I
shouldn't say oversensitive sensitive to
it but just as you are mentioning your
cultural background and how
expressiveness differs across culture
the expressions differ across culture if
if you want to develop good technology
for say AI deployment you need diverse
datasets right I mean it's just like
exactly it's a necessity it's not a
luxury it's not an option if you want
good technology in certainly this type
of technology you just you need to have
complete data sets and diverse data sets
and I find that practically and
metaphorically reassuring if that makes
sense yeah absolutely if you want you
know if you're going to
deploy this technology which we do in
like 90 countries around the world
you can't just train it on people that
look like you Tim right which is which
is which would be the default kind of
default data set and so we we really
prioritize the diversity of the data but
you can't get to the diversity of the
data unless you have a diverse team of
people who are thinking about the data
and the algorithm and and and like you
know how robust it is globally and cross
culturally so that's where I think the
conversation about diversity and
inclusion becomes really real because
you want a diverse group of minds and
brains thinking about this problem and
how to solve it in a way that works for
everybody and it's not just diversity of
like gender or ethnicity which is what
people usually gravitate to I'm you know
we think diversity of age is very
important because so we have a high
school internship program for for high
school kids where we bring them in and
of course they learn a lot but we learn
a lot from them too because their
experience growing up with technology is
very different than say mine I'm in my
you know I'm 41 and you know and these
and these kids are just a very different
experience growing up with devices and
technologies and we want their
perspective and they're gonna be the
ones who are kind of stuck with this
technology right so I think they need to
have a voice around the table as well so
all kinds of diversity not just an even
like you know our CMOS and how is an art
historian and she you know is very
involved in product strategy so we want
her around the table to it's not just
machine learning folks like me so yeah I
think it's really really key and the
cultural piece is huge - right because
you could have for those who don't know
I'm gonna look like a Danish man which I
am in part literally the huge fat head
bald now at this point but you can find
people like me in Scandinavia you can
find people like me here in the US who
look like me you can find people who
look somewhat like me even in Egypt
right I have some Egyptian friends who
have uh they have blue eyes and in the
case of my friends red hair but what's
your ball
the hair color matter it matters less
Albania etc and culturally they're going
to express quite differently where it's
it's it's possibly they would so I I'm
excited to see where the technology goes
I hope that it's there's more.they
enabling benevolence or at least neutral
direction as opposed to sort of
dystopian police state direction but I
suspect we'll have a bit of both and at
least speaking for one person I'm glad
that you have the ethical direction and
sort of values that you've put in place
for making decisions right because
you're going to have to I mean
ultimately you have to program that
decision-making framework into the
company in the same way that you'll be
programming rules and decision making
possibly into the into the lines of code
that dictate the behaviors of artificial
intelligence but I really think I mean
on goal of the book is to spark public
dialogue around human centric AI because
I really think it's there is so much
amazing potential for this technology
has immuno safer roads like you name it
and yes there are lots of potential for
abuse but who's making the decision it's
us like we as a society are the ones who
are bearing it in whatever direction
like we are going to spend my chair and
investment money to steer it in the
direction we want it to and I really
want the public to be part of that
conversation just the same way you know
there is a movement towards you know
greener products or Fairtrade or
whatever we need the same in a I think
the consumer can can have a voice in in
prioritizing or really kind of
supporting companies that have these
strong core values and and supporting
less of the companies that don't vote
with your wallet vote with your voice is
the only thing and this is this is
sometimes difficult question for folks
to answer but just to to tie up here if
you had a billboard metaphor
speaking something that you you could
use to get a message out to billions of
people but limited real estate so you
could put a quote word a sentence
anything non-commercial on this what
might you a question an image what might
you put on that billboard to convey to
share with billions of people and
anything come to mind that's a tough one
because a billboard um
and embrace your emotion like embrace
your emotions that's like the call to
action yeah I love it
yeah okay that works for me
embrace your emotion hashtag brace
emotions yeah yeah you will be you will
be with your emotions whether you like
it or not whether you try to silence
them or not I think it's more better to
embrace embrace your emotions I I think
that's perfectly power in that I think
it's power right there's power in that
it's it's it's actually powerful that's
what we want to convey yeah absolutely
so anything else that you would like to
say before we wrap up here today no I'm
just easy to find if people want to
reach out and share their stories or
their input or ideas there any on social
are you more active anywhere in
particular do your preferred social
location um LinkedIn changed to just is
pretty new but the other thing there's a
lot of conversation on LinkedIn um yeah
that's and that's call you be I would
imagine there are too many people on
LinkedIn the exact same name that's my
guess
did you does your name mean anything
might not my name really does not
doesn't that much meaning to it but does
yours have any meanings there my first
name means serenity right serene right
um and which which I have to work on I'm
not that serene like get into my Z I
need to like practice meditation or
something
been my on my new year's resolutions
forever and then my last name is Fred
it's it's it's like how you be as in
from Cal U or Cali obey a which is a
govern government in Egypt
it's a place in Egypt serenity Radha
don't we all need a little bit more
serenity I this has been a really fun
conversation for me people can find you
on LinkedIn that's Hollywood being
worked all this in the show notes of
course on Twitter at Kali will be once
again that's ka li o ub y instagram @
rana
el khalili OB and the website where you
can find all of this is probably the
easiest home base which is Rael Kali be
calm and for everybody listening you can
find all of the links to everything
we've discussed including the book at
Tim vlog forward slash podcast Rama
thank you so much for taking the time
today this has been a lot of fun for me
thank you thank you for having me and
for everybody out there listen you're
watching
don't be an upper lip razor also
something else for folks be well be safe
and thanks for tuning in
you